hello everyone i'm alan and welcome to
my channel where today
uh i thought that i would watch the
black myth wukong official trailer with
you guys
we originally saw this game and i did
have a video up about it in
august of 2020 i think it was um made by
a chinese studio based on journey to the
west um for any of you who aren't
familiar with that story
you might know it from enslaved made by
ninja theory or maybe you know it from
dragon ball
a lot of things that pull from this
particular story that that is a chinese
story that is very very cool
um and yeah it's made by game science
who are on screen right now it seemed to
me more like the original and i think
they might have even said this um
gameplay that we saw was a bit more of a
tech demo or even a recruitment video
designed to
tell people the kind of tone that the
game is looking for
or potentially
to just show people what they're working
on but it wasn't it wasn't for marketing
purposes it seemed like it was for
internal purposes um like a vertical
slice kind of thing
this says official trailer where the
other one was not an official trailer
technically um if i have that
correct so this is probably intended to
be viewed by audiences like us
it could look different to the original
trailer it could look worse
um because i think they do serve
different purposes but who knows doesn't
have a release date yet
uh unless there's one in here i guess we
should watch it let's do it
and also this aspect ratio is very
strange i don't know what's happening
here
but let's do it
make sure i'm watching this at the right
quality
no thank you oh wow
stunning
extreme sakura vibes for obvious reasons
very impressed by the texture work i
mean that's exceptionally sakura
so is this oddly
[Music]
i love the look of the animation
the lighting effects
[Music]
that implies some kind of a skill tree i
think
cool
[Music]
music is also very nice
didn't he turned into a bug in the first
video
more of that
beautiful i always judge fire in video
games
um sometimes it's just 2d even call of
duty like even the most recent ones just
2d fire
[Music]
also the stone banks probably should
have said it is a manga but i said bangs
because my head went to slaps
we'll just move past that
[Music]
be strong like a bull huh all right
[Music]
video is specially produced for
celebrating the year of the ox it does
not represent actual plot
got it okay so the video is
is more of a celebration of the
beginning of the year of the ox
well worth noting um still looks awesome
a new trailer for black myth wukong a
new action adventure rpg from chinese
developer game science based on the
journey to the west mythology
that's awesome um apparently
here you go thank you spamming tea
they said it means developing is still
working fine recruiting available so
it's still in development and going
well i suppose to loosely translate that
but they're still trying to recruit to
work on the game it's probably
a ways out yeah maybe still not an
actual real trailer a lot of people
saying that
um that's probably lost in translation i
guess
but it yeah it looks really really cool
um
very neat i feel like this game is still
probably really far away
but yeah the journey to the west uh is
i just wanted to pull this up just for
informational purposes for anyone who's
curious about what it's based on
wikipedia the number one source is a
chinese novel published in the 16th
century
during the ming dynasty and attributed
to wu chang in it is one of the four
great classical novels of chinese
literature it has been described as
arguably the most popular literary work
in east asia i feel like that's fair
um arthur whaley's a bridge version
monkey is known in
english-speaking countries i wonder if
they note video games here
because definitely here you go
dragon ball dream of the red chamber
enslaved such a good game
such a good game still holds up romance
of the three kingdoms starsing a water
margin and the god of high school would
be some of the most popular
ones but uh yeah definitely a popular oh
ah you caught my eye at australia being
australian
australia's abc tvnz and netflix
announced production was underway in new
zealand on a new live-action series the
new legends of monkey
to premiere globally in 2018. did it
come out
i guess it did there you go
there ongoing cool um yeah the super
quick one
just wanted to see more of it really
still impressed by the lighting effects
still worth noting this is all fully
subject to change
but uh it is a very cool story a very
cool
character feels weird to say when it's
based on something like this but uh
i think it's neat and i would like to
see more sign me up please
um it for me today everyone just thought
i'd watch it with you guys because it's
going to watch it anyway so why not
i will see you all next time bye